wastelanders rejoice the latest fallout  4 patch is now available for PlayStation  4 and Xbox one patch 1.3 which released  last week for PC can now be downloaded  on your preferred console this patch was  originally supposed to launch alongside  the PC patch late last week but as  you've probably guessed that didn't  happen according to a tweet from  developer bethesda softworks the patch  improve stability and performance and  fixes a number of bugs including a  glitch where a player or NPC could  become dismembered while still alive the  update also improves object fading  distance which isn't nearly as gruesome  other fixes include pieces now snap  together more easily in workshop bowed  players can now build work benches in  their diamond city home and companions  can no longer get stuck with radiation  poisoning for the full patch notes and  our look at a Witcher themed gear mod  created by a modern named wren head over  to gamespot com  you